مدى شمولية كأس العالم هذه
ستكون شاملة للغاية ،
نرحب بالجميع ، فنحن لا نضع
أي قيود على أي جنسية أو
أي شخص فيما يتعلق
بدين التوجه الجنساني - إن
حضور كأس العالم للأمن هو أمر في
غاية الأهمية ونحن لا نفعل ذلك.  ننظر إلى
الأمر من منظور التوجه الديني للعرق ،
فنحن ننظر إلى سلامة
وأمن المعجبين أي معجب بأهمية قصوى
والأولوية التي
توصي بها أن يخفي شخص ما من مجتمع المثليين
جنسيته عندما
يأتون إلى هنا.
دولة وقطر هي دولة متواضعة
من حيث العرض العام للعاطفة أمر مرفوض
بشكل عام ، لذا فإن ما أقترحه
هو إظهار المودة بشكل عام
يؤخذ في الاعتبار أن قطر
دولة محافظة ولا
أقول إظهارًا علنيًا للمودة
تجاه أي شخص.  الجنس أو أي توجه جنسي
أتحدث عنه للجميع هل هذه
مسألة قبول الإدراك أليس
هذا من صميم الإنسانية التي نصنعها
تأكد من أن الجميع مرتاحون
ولديهم إحساس قليل بوطنهم هنا
أيضًا ، وفي المقابل نطلب
أن يدرك الناس أيضًا أننا ثقافة
لها أعرافها الخاصة وليست ثقافة فريدة
وليست مجموعة فريدة  من
الأعراف ، هل تعتقد أن كاثارز حظيت بتجربة عادلة
في الصحافة من حيث الدعاية لها
وأن التعزيزات الحديثة كانت
تعامل قطر بشكل غير عادل ، نعم في رأيي
كثيرًا ، لذا أعتقد أن قطر
قد حكم عليها من قبل محكمة الإدراك.
في وقت مبكر بدأت مع
التنهدات بدأت مع الطقس
وكانت هناك قضايا الفساد
وكانت هناك قضايا رعاية العمال
أنا لا أقول أن بعض
الأشياء عادلة وبعض الأشياء
التي أدركناها وبعضها  الأشياء
التي نعتقد أنها تمثل تحديات نحتاج إلى
القيام بشيء حيالها عندما يتعلق الأمر
برفاهية العمال ، لقد رفعنا أيدينا في
وقت مبكر جدًا وقلنا أن هذا مجال
يمثل تحديًا ونعلم
أنه يجب أن يكون هناك الكثير من العمل
لا احد يستطيع  ننكر اليوم ليس من قبلنا بقول هذا ولكن من
قبل الهيئات المعترف بها دوليًا
حجم العمل الذي تم إدخاله في التشريع ومقدار العمل الذي
ذهب لتحسين
ظروف العمال وقد تعلمون
في رأيي أن سابقة أعمالنا هذه هي
سرعة  الطريقة التي حدثت بها الأمور
هنا كان تقرير العفو الأخير
الذي يقول إنك أخفقت في
الوفاء بوعود معالجة استغلال العمال المهاجرين.
القوانين وتغيير السلوكيات هي
أن الأمر يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً ولا
يحدث بين عشية وضحاها حتى عندما يتعلق
الأمر بالفساد الذي جعلنا أنفسنا
في أعلى درجات التقدير خلال مرحلة تقديم العطاءات
بعد سنوات وسنوات
وسنوات وسنوات من التحقيق كان ذلك فقط
يتم إلقاء القبض عليك وما زلت تسمع
تسمعه أحيانًا في الصحافة ولا
يزال هناك دائمًا ذلك الثانوي الذي يتم منحه بشكل
مشكوك فيه أو شيء من هذا
القبيل وهذا بالنسبة لنا هو  nfair
لأننا حوكمنا في محكمة عامة
حوكمنا من
قبل الصحافة وحوكمنا من قبل جميع الناس ومن جميع
مناحي الحياة في وسائل الإعلام ثم كان لدينا FIFA
يحقق ثم كان هناك
تحقيق و  نحن  أن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
كان متورطًا ، ثم كان هناك
تحقيق من قبل المدعي العام
لسويسرا ، أعني أنك تعرف ما هو
الشيء الذي أريد أن أقوله لك في
صميم النظام القانوني في الغرب
حتى تثبت إدانتنا
أنه لم يتم تمديد  كنا مذنبين
وكان علينا أن نستمر في إثبات براءتنا
مرارًا وتكرارًا لماذا
هذا سؤال أود أن أطرحه عليك ،
سأطلب من الأشخاص الذين سيشاهدون هذه
المقابلة لو كانت
أمة أخرى هل سيتم قياسها
بنفس الشيء  قياس مقدار المفاجأة
التي كانت عليها ، أعتقد أننا نتوقعها ،
لا أعتقد أننا كنا نتوقع مدى
شدتها ، كيف يمكنك تغيير
ما أعتقده ، أعتقد أنه كان هناك الكثير
من الوقت الذي حظي به بعض الأشخاص
تراجع الآن وقلنا دعونا ننظر إلى
هذا بموضوعية أعتقد أن الأمور
بدأت في تغيير المفاهيم
بدأت في تغيير الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين انتقدوا الكثير من الصحفيين
الذين هم خبراء في هذا المجال والذين
جلسوا كتبوا.  كلمات قليلة عن كوتا ،
لم أطأ قدماي هنا
وأقول لهم دائمًا أنك بحاجة إلى القدوم إلى هنا
واكتب ما تريد أن تكتبه ،
انتقد بقدر ما تنتقد ولكن
لديك بعض المصداقية ، تعال هنا أولاً